[Music]
high ambitions are noble and important
but there can also come a point when
they become the sources of terrible
trouble and unnecessary panic
one way of undercutting our
perfectionist impulses was pioneered by
a British psychoanalyst
called Donald Winnicott in the 1950s
Winnicott specialized in relationships
between parents and children in his
clinical practice he often met with
parents who felt like failures perhaps
because their children hadn't got into
the best schools or because there were
sometimes arguments around the dinner
table or the house wasn't always
completely tidy winnicott's crucial
insight was that the parents agony was
coming from a particular place excessive
hope their despair was a consequence of
a cruel and counterproductive
perfectionism so as to help them reduce
this when it got developed a charming
phrase his parents needed to feel that
they were good enough parents no child
he insisted need an ideal parent they
just need an okay pretty decent usually
well-intentioned sometimes a bit grumpy
but basically reasonable father or
mother
Winnicott wasn't saying this because he
liked to settle for second best but
because he knew from firsthand the toll
exact it by perfectionism and realized
that in order to remain more or less
sane which is a pretty big ambition
already we have to learn not to hate
ourselves for failing to be what no
ordinary human being ever really is
anyway
the concept of good enough was invented
as an escape from dangerous ideals
it began in relation to Parenthood but
it can actually be applied across life
more generally especially around work
and love a relationship may be good
enough even while it has many dark
moments perhaps at times there's little
sex and a lot of heavy arguments maybe
there are big areas of loneliness and
non communication
yet none of this should lead us to feel
freakish or unnaturally unlucky it can
be good enough similarly a good enough
job will be very boring at some points
it won't perfectly utilize all our
merits we won't earn a fortune but we
may make some real friends have times of
genuine excitement and finish many days
tired but with a sense of true
accomplishment it takes a good deal of
bravery and skill to keep even a very
ordinary life going to persevere through
the challenges of love work and children
is quietly heroic we should perhaps more
often sometimes step back in order to
acknowledge in a non starry-eyed but
very real way that our lives are good
enough and that this is in itself
already a very grand achievement did you
know that the school of life is actually
a place ten places in fact campuses all
over the world from Melbourne to London
Taipei to Istanbul with classes and
books and lots more please click on the
link below to explore more